[Música]
nosotros continuamos cada vez más
compañías le apuestan al desarrollo de
la Inteligencia artificial como
impulsora de publicidad y de ingresos
esta semana el multimillonario elon musk
lanzó su startup de Inteligencia
artificial shay Google amplió su chatbot
Bart que ahora está disponible en Europa
y Brasil y de openea y sigue creciendo
vamos a conversar sobre estas
tecnologías con Alejandro
cofundador de botmaker y experto en
Inteligencia artificial para lenguaje
natural bienvenido France 24 Qué
diferencias podemos encontrar entre
estas ofertas de Inteligencia artificial
para interactuar con los usuarios
Buenos días Valentina y a toda la
audiencia las diferencias son en las
capacidades que tiene cada una de estas
inteligencias las plataformas se van a
especializando en algunas capacidades
puntuales por ejemplo en el caso de chat
gpt resuelve muy bien la construcción
del lenguaje no así el acceso a la
información en tiempo real chachipití es
más una demostración de las capacidades
de este modelo que un producto en sí
mismo y se ha utilizado para que las
compañías empiecen a adoptar las
herramientas y construir sus propias
soluciones en el caso de Bart Por
ejemplo si bien también es una solución
para empresas está un poquito más
enfocado en el usuario final y tiene
capacidades para responder información
más real en base a la información que
tiene Google e información que que está
disponible en la web en tiempo real
sobre elon musk y el lanzamiento nuevo
la verdad es que no tenemos mucha
información sobre Qué productos van a
ser pero por sus dichos tiene varios
intereses una es proveer de un cierto
marco de lo que se llama alineamiento
entre la máquina o entre la Inteligencia
artificial y el ser humano Entonces el
modelo va a partir con ciertas elementos
de seguridad o lo que se llama el
problema de alainment que es el problema
de asegurar que la Inteligencia
artificial en el futuro va a estar bajo
las órdenes de los seres humanos y por
otro lado está interesado en la
exploración del universo Así que está
más interesada en conocer el origen del
universo y en utilizar la Inteligencia
artificial para ese tiempo Bueno si
hablamos puntualmente de ti hay algo que
llama la atención y es que el tráfico
mensual del sitio web y Los visitantes
únicos disminuyeron por primera vez en
junio Cómo considera usted que será
ahora pues esta competencia
claro Hay competencia Y eso se nota por
un lado pero no no diría que es una una
baja de su éxito o de su impacto todo lo
contrario lo que nos fijamos en los
productos una vez que llegan a cierto
volumen es en la frecuencia de usos es
decir qué tanto vuelven los usuarios que
lo han utilizado y vemos que chachi piti
está haciendo una herramienta y sobre
todo los llaman las apis o las
herramientas que están detrás de ti
están siendo implementadas en un montón
de soluciones alrededor del mundo el
caso de chipity hay que verlo más como
una materia prima para construir otras
soluciones este que están implementando
otras empresas por ejemplo
principalmente Microsoft para sus
herramientas de de Office no del office
suite
es un producto y Y sí hay mucha
competencia y vamos a ver cada vez más
ofertas ahí propuestas también de
diferentes modelos Open source muchos
basados en modelos de meta que que están
siendo disponibles y que nosotros mismos
los estamos probando bueno Qué
beneficios traen por ejemplo por un lado
para los creadores pero también para los
consumidores estas interacciones con las
diferentes herramientas
hoy estas herramientas son
principalmente para la construcción de
lenguaje es decir ayudan a escribir y a
crear lenguaje de una manera mucho más
productiva y como los trabajos de
oficina principalmente consisten en la
creación de lenguaje escribimos mails
hacemos presentaciones escribimos
documentos es una gran herramienta que
incrementa la productividad en todos los
trabajos de escritorio o todos los
trabajos de oficina hay una hay algo que
yo siempre advierto un poco a los
usuarios que es no considerar aún por lo
menos a la Inteligencia artificial como
tal chipití para la búsqueda de
información la información No
necesariamente va a ser correcta muchas
veces la inteligencia decimos alucina
crea información adicional porque su
característica es la creación del
lenguaje no la búsqueda de información
real entonces todo lo que esté orientado
en crear contenido inclusive hasta crear
notas periodísticas blogs etcétera donde
luego un ser humano es quien certifica
la información y valida este que ese
contenido se pueda publicar
bueno hablando un poco más en un sentido
general algo que llama mucho la atención
y que y sobre lo que se ha hecho énfasis
es que todos estos programas y todos
estos algoritmos algoritmos están
programados en inglés y que al
traducirlos al español por ejemplo puede
haber una pérdida de fidelidad de lo que
se está tratando de ordenar Qué puede
usted decir al respecto la importancia
de programar en español
sí es es común que al principio los
productos tengan mayor disponibilidad y
mayor eficacia en inglés porque hay más
contenido sobre el cual que se utilizó
para entrenar la verdad es que internet
hoy tiene más contenido en inglés en
cualquier otro idioma y esto permite que
los entrenamientos sean más precisos al
inicio pero no es algo que dure
justamente el lanzamiento de Bart en
español y en portugués así como en un
montón de otros idiomas el día de ayer
públicamente da el indicio de que las
plataformas y las herramientas ya están
disponibles en otros idiomas y yo Me
sentiría muy cómodo de hecho nosotros
utilizamos la plataforma de Bart con su
Api que se llama vertex dentro de la
compañía y en español en portuguesa está
funcionando muy bien
Hay que animarse sí diría que para los
idiomas que tienen poco uso en el mundo
que son un poco más locales o más de de
digamos que por ejemplo el guaraní o o
otros idiomas que son muy locales y que
no tiene tanta documentación publicada
van a tener un poco más de de dificultad
en entrenar los modelos pero diría yo el
español el inglés el francés el chino el
coreano este son idiomas el árabe son
idiomas de mucha utilización que junto
al inglés yo estaría tranquilo que se
pueden utilizar bueno algo que llama
también la atención de las tartas de
elon musk Pues que fue lanzada por el
millonario él muchas veces ha dicho que
se debe pausar el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial y que el sector
necesita una regulación No solo él
yofrey Hilton padre padrino de la
Inteligencia artificial también hizo
unas recomendaciones en mayo pasado
Ellos dicen que pues la Inteligencia
artificial podría potencialmente causar
De cierto modo de una destrucción de
algunos trabajos como los conocemos
incluso Pues también generar como chat
información falsa que para una persona
normal una persona promedio pues no es
posible
reconocer y también que incluso en un
futuro las armas podrían los robots
podrían llegar a ser armas mortales qué
se puede pensar o qué deberíamos
nosotros analizar de estas advertencias
sí es más una expresión de deseo que una
posibilidad el pausar el desarrollo del
Progreso y de hecho mi recomendación
probablemente sería la opuesta decir
pausar el desarrollo en ciertas partes
del mundo lo único que va a dar es
ventaja a otras partes del mundo que la
van a continuar desarrollando como
siempre las las debilidades de un modelo
o las amenazas que puede tener un modelo
Se resuelven con más desarrollo y más
producto y lanzando productos
superadores por eso es que para mí ese
esperanzador de hecho el lanzamiento de
X punto bayay de elon más porque es una
respuesta haciendo algo más que más que
tratando de prohibirlo de detenerlo El
Progreso es prácticamente es imposible
detener más en modelos de desarrollo
donde hay miles o millones de developers
de programadores en todo el mundo que lo
van a continuar desarrollando y que por
más que se saque una ley o se haga un
acuerdo este van a ver desarrollos que
van a continuar esto es
es importante construir acuerdos
sobre ciertos estándares que permitan
establecer calidad y formas de
desarrollo pero no no lo veo que lo
podamos detener